[Musica]
Oh
capitano
voi amate il mare
sì Io l'amo il mare è tutto
copre 7 decimi del globo terrestre il
suo respiro è puro e sano
è luogo dove l'uomo non si sente mai
solo perché sente premere la vita
accanto a sé nasconde miracoli di pura
bellezza
il mistero del corallo che ci regala
colore non se ne accorge i pesci e la
segreta Vittoria che celebrano
squali delfini balene capodogli che
nessun essere umano è in grado di
guardare senza provare uno stupore
antico
un giorno vedi il fluttuare delle Pinne
la grazia senza gravità del nuoto e
senti L'Antico richiamo il desiderio
irresistibile di tornare ad essere acqua
in quel momento apparve un capodoglio mi
fissò negli occhi in quel momento capì
che io e lui eravamo uguali la stessa
cosa
entrambi destinati
all'estinzione sei Il sottile equilibrio
su cui ci reggevamo si fosse rotto
Lascia che ti guidi nel mio viaggio
proverò a mostrarti la via in mezzo alle
rovine tieni lo sguardo sempre alto e
vigile e tutto si farà più chiaro non
appena vedrai le creature lungo il tuo
percorso
[Musica]
perché
i miei figli piangono
Quale mano vuole ferirli
Quale cuore vorrebbe vederli soffrire
Io sono il mare mi innalzo alla luna con
un canto e poi torno ad abbracciare la
terra
sono acqua che nutre acqua che respira
perché i miei figli piangono Quale mano
vuole ferirli Quale cuore vorrebbe
vederli soffrire
[Musica]
[Applauso]
che io
piango
qui a crudo sorte
mentre respiro
[Musica]
per te
Lascia
che io pianga miracolo
[Musica]
Wow
una sorte
mentre esasperò
[Musica]
lì
per
[Musica]
dicono che il mare è freddo e invece
contiene il sangue più caldo il più
Selvaggio il più impetuoso
[Musica]
1820 quasi 200 anni fa a 1.200 miglia
nautiche a ovest delle isole Galapagos
l'equipaggio della baleniera Essex
ha visto un branco di capodogli
l'equipaggio non esitò a estrarre gli
Arpioni e colpo dopo colpo sterminarono
il branco
già pregustavano tutto il denaro che
avrebbero tratto portando al re tutto
quel grasso di balena
baldestino
aveva in serbo qualcosa di diverso per
loro
Un enorme capodoglio passato alla storia
col nome di Moby Dick spinto da un senso
di difesa e protezione nei confronti del
proprio Branco della propria famiglia
del proprio gruppo si scagliò contro gli
Arpioni contro la nave e con due colpi
devastanti condannò la baleniera sul
fondo del Pacifico per sempre
l'affondamento di una nave non è mai un
evento da celebrare tranne nel caso in
cui rappresenti un raro momento nella
storia in cui la natura si fa giustizia
contro i soprusi dell'uomo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
l'olio di balena illuminava città come
Londra e Parigi nel 1800 ora non più si
è scoperto che le balene sono
fondamentali per la sopravvivenza
dell'uomo con le loro feci concimano le
morbide praterie di Posidonia che
sprigionano l'ossigeno che l'uomo
respira ogni giorno eppure l'uomo
continua a cacciarle
[Musica]
[Applauso]
con ogni mezzo solchi le mie acque e
credi di poter conquistare tutti i miei
spazi
è più importante un riccio un uomo un
delfino un ape o una balena
sai qual è l'unica vera risposta
che dipendiamo l'uno dall'altro che
siamo la stessa cosa
sai qual è l'unica vera risposta
che abbiamo la scelta
possiamo scegliere se essere i
protagonisti e responsabili della nostra
condanna o della nostra salvezza
possiamo scegliere di proteggere questa
meraviglia
proteggimi
proteggiti
Difendimi difenditi
[Musica]
ti sei mai chiesto
a cosa ti è servita andare in fondo
cercare con i piedi in buona pace Un
angolo nascosto e poi
rilassato
ti vuoi successo e non sapere più perché
con me
di non avere fiato nei polmoni a corto
di respiri da solo come regalo
[Musica]
quasi ritornarla
sembra l'unica risposta
[Musica]
l'unico risposta
Cosa hai imparato mentre andavi in fondo
tirato giù dal peso di ogni dubbio che
ci vuole coraggio e poi uno slancio
[Musica]
esplode in quel momento
mentre cerco i colori
però sembra quasi di toccarla
[Musica]
l'unica risposta
il vostro ascolto è già un'azione
e sta creando un'onda
tante onde possono addirittura invertire
il corso di una nave e quella nave che
aveva sterminato ora il branco di Moby
Dick potrà forse tornare in porto e
fermarsi e potrà trasformarsi nella nave
che invece di uccidere gli animali li
difende e li può proteggere
quella nave possiamo essere noi onda
dopo onda
Io sono coralli e vi saluto con l'ultima
canzone e con un invito ad andare a
scoprire cosa fanno le navi di si
Shepherd conosciuti anche come la flotta
di Nettuno e i Pastori del mare tutte le
canzoni che avete sentito oggi sono
dedicate alla loro missione di difendere
e proteggere il mare e le sue creature
candidato sale and Fight for Life c'è
lei
[Musica]
Uhm
cammina
[Musica]
susina's One